もう一つだけやります
オーワデイヤアヌサーセイヤアサブハチャニワラエ
サタヒソピヨーティアサタホーティヤンピヨ
オーワデイヤっていうのはアドバイスすること
アヌサーセイヤっていうのはアドバイスすること
何が違いますかね あまり何も違いはないんです
ただ単語 2つです しかし
パーリ語で単語 2つあるということは
このパーリ語ではよく大事なことなんです
日本語ではそんな単語がないということは
人に教えてもらうということはあまり気にしないんだからなんですね
生まれる時はもう我が輩はもう世界一だっていうことだから
人に教えてもらう身分じゃないんですね
だから言語が少ないといえば
そこを興味ないということなんです
その文化は で 私は英語の単語今考えてみたんですけれど
instructions とかね
アドバイスとアドバイスというのは英語の言葉ですからね
だから instructions と advice なんです
オーワデイヤっていうのはアドバイス
アヌサーセイヤというのは instruction
instruct では
それどんな違いますかね
アドバイスの場合はだいたいまあ悪いことをしたり
あれやこれやったり まあこんなことやるなよとかね
こうこうしなさいよとか
なんでそんなことするのかとかね
というふうな感じで まあ叱り
ことも叱ることも入ってます
アヌサーサナの場合は叱ること入ってないんです
こうであるべきですよと
こうこうするべきだよと
まあわかりやすく言えば
本人が間違いはしている場合はオーワダなんです
何も間違いはしてない場合はアヌサーサナなんです
だから成長する人はこの両方も受けますよ
いろんなもう勉強したり修行したりする場合はいろいろ失敗はする
失敗するときはオーワダになっちゃうんです
まあ淡々と頑張っている場合はアヌサーサナなんですね
はい ではこうしましょう
ではこうしましょうという風にアヌサーサナになっちゃうんです
そういうことで オーワデイヤアヌサーセイヤ
アドバイスをする  instructionsはくれる
アサブハチャニワラエ
アサブハサッビヒ サブハっていうのは文化的ということで
社会的ということで まあ悪い
良いというか アサブハっていうのはとても悪いことなんですね
いわゆる悪ですね チャニワラエ
品のない悪いことからもうやめさせる
ストップさせる それである人がいる
その人はオーワダもするし
アヌサーサナもするし
アドバイスもするし instruction
もあげるし それで悪いことからちゃんともうガードしてくれるし
悪いこともできんようにしてあげたりするし
その人のこと うるさいんですね
はっきり言えば しょっちゅういろいろこと言われるとね
こうしなさい ああしなさいと
うるさいと思うでしょ
出来が悪い人はうるさいと思いますよと
良い人はその人のことをとても大事にするんだよと
サタヒソピヨーティ その人のことサタン
サタンっていうのはグッドパーソンですかね
善人ですかね 善人ならその人のことを好きになるんだと
アサタンっていうのは悪人ですね
悪人には嫌われると 善人に好まれる
悪人に嫌われる 誰のこと？しょっちゅうアドバイスする人のことなんです
悪いことはもうちょっと遊びにでもやらせてくれないんですね
厳しい 悪いことはやらせてくれないわ
アドバイスするわ あれこれやってインストラクションするわと
まあ四六時うるさいと
うるさいと思う人は決まって悪人なんですね
なんてすごい人ですかと
この人のところでもうもう 1ヶ月間でも強引にでもいなくちゃいけないと思う人はもう善人なんですね
この二つでも我々に教えているのは賢者はなんせではないんです
賢者になるためにはなんです
智慧のある人になりたいんですか？と
だったらこれが必要だと
この性格は この資格 で
まあこの基本資格はこの二つで終わりと思いますけどね
これから別な別なこと
お釈迦様の時代であるお坊さんたち二人がいて
それもサーリプッタ尊者のところに出家した二人なんですけど
これやけに現代人っぽくて
であるキータギリという場所でね
普通のお坊さん お釈迦様もよく行かない別な地方でね
まあたまに行きますけどね
それももう何年 何年行くかわからないしね
この二人がそちら辺で村人
町の人々と仲良くなって
随分仲良くなって 現代的に生活しているんです
でお寺は一生懸命いろいろ子供たちやら若者呼んでもらって
花畑を作ったり もうちゃんと計画立てて
こちら黄色い花を植えましょう
こちらは赤い花にしましょう
こちら大きい木を植えましょう
こちら小さな池作りましょうとかね
で こちら小石を拭いている
ちょっとした道路を作りましょうとかね
こういう作業をやらせるんですね
で それからお祭りに参加する
村人のなんかお祭り 盆踊りとかあったら
この二人に行って まあ衣を置いておいて踊ると
みんなと一緒に 衣着たままでは踊れませんからね
お寺はよく楽しかったとかね
で 寺に戻ると で 村人も本当に喜んで
なんていういいお坊さんですかと
全くもう我々と全くも一緒で仲良くしてくれて
我々を出家出そうとかね
そんなことは何のこともなく
ということですごい喜んで人気で
ものすごい説教 だから托鉢とかにも行く必要もないんで
パーティーですね みんな集めて
結婚式でもあると言ったら
まあそうですか あんた結婚するの
では私たちも行きますよと言って
結婚式に行って そこでパーティーして
で そこそんな感じで もうやりたい放題
よくあることは 人々を見る限り
何々さん おはようございます
今日お元気ですね 今日はいい天気ですねとかと
みんなとよく喋る その町の人々の名前やら職業やらもう全部知っていて
だから顔を合わせたらもうすぐお坊さんたちが名前で何々さん
どう元気？今日はもう今日は畑で
今日は田んぼですか？今日は森ですか？とかね
今の時期だったらやっぱり山菜する時期だから
よく森に行くんですね
まあ頑張ってください
熊に気をつけてとかね
まあそういうふうな話で
結構人気 その村にある日ある阿羅漢が行ったんです
旅するでこの町を通らなくちゃいけないし
で 町といったっても ちょっと大きさがインドの大きさだからね
これ一日かかります で
昼は托鉢に行ったんですけど
ご存知のように 下を見て
誰とお元気ですか？とかね
それ何もなく 一言もかけることなく
鉢を持って みんな なんだその坊主は
なんか病気になってる感じ
だけけ機嫌悪そうやとかね
人の顔は見ないんだと
なんか変だ 気持ち悪いと
全然誰も托鉢をもうあまりもうその考え方もそうはてさえもないんで
それにしたらもう同じ形に衣を着てる
我々のお坊さんお二人はね
この間 うちの子供の誕生会にも来てね
一緒に踊って歌を歌ってね
ご飯食べて帰ったのに
これにしてたらなんだこの人はと
誰もご飯ひとさじもくれない
そこで仏教を本当に知っているある一人の信者さんが男性がいたんですね
そしたら みんなに批判されるのを
バカにされるのを見て
こそっとお坊さんのところに行って 「
お坊さん ゆっくりそっと私の家に来てください」と
自分の家に隠れて呼んでもらって
ご食事をしてあげて お布施をして
まあせっかくお釈迦様が来てね
町をね この仏教にしてあげたんですけど
今はある二人がね 全部改稿していますよと
もうどうにもならんと
だから我々はブッダの道を歩む我々はもう隠れて一言も喋らないことにしているんだよと
でもこれってすごくまずいんだから
お釈迦様に報告してくださいと
その信者さんも悟りに達している人なんです
それでお釈迦様にその話を言ったところで
よくよくご本人の間で起きた話題は
これは何ともできんと
大人気だと あの二人はあの国で
それに対してお釈迦様おっしゃったことはこの芸なんです
それはその通りだと 人々を正しく導く人のことは嫌うと
悪人は 善人ならその人のことを好きになります
ですから お釈迦様の弟子たちがその町に行ってね
仏道はそんなものではありませんと言ったならば
国中みんなに嫌われるんです
これすごく大きな問題になったんだから
お釈迦様の時代でもね
やっぱり それでのお釈迦様がいろいろ智慧がありますからね
お釈迦様はこれでまずサーリプッタ尊者に呼んでね
あの二人は誰の弟子ですか？と言ったら
本当は私のところに住居したんだよと
だったらあなたの責任でしょうと
破門するのも サーリプッタ尊者はそういうことをやりたくはないんです
すごいもう優しいんですよ
もう 言ったら じゃあモクレン尊者と一緒に行ってみなさいと言ったら
でも社会情勢はどうでしょうかと
世間の気持ちはどうしましょうかと
で お釈迦様がそれは別に気にすることはなく
あんた方は二人では危ないんだと
ですから 人三百人ぐらいお坊さんたちさあ
それで出なさいと 言って
何のことなくそのお寺に行って
そこでこの戒律の儀式があります
この戒律の儀式で正式的に破門しなさいと
破門というのは地方から追い出すんです
戒律を破ったら減束させればいいんだから
もう破ってはいますけど
むちゃくちゃむちゃくちゃ
でも減束させる所まではいかないんですね
一緒に踊っただけとかね
一緒にご飯食べた パーティーでご飯食べたとかね
そんな程度で花畑作ったりとかね
もう美しい庭園作ったとかね
それは戒律違反ですけど
破門するまでには 減束させるまでにはいかないんですね
それでサンガでいわゆる追放する儀式を行ったら
二人がもう出て行かなくちゃいけない
それで村人たちにもなんかお坊さんたちが集めて
すごいなんか会議やったみたいやとね
あの二人はどこかに別な場所にトランスと英語で言いますけど
何と言いますか 職業移転させると
会社で別なところに行かせることを何と言いますか
転勤で転勤  転勤 転勤 なんか転勤させたみたいという勘違いしてね
だからあの二人はすごく明るく生きてきたけど
今はもう責任のお坊さんはあんまりそういうことをしないとか
それで何のことなく じわじわじわじわと大騒ぎが冷やしてはいきましたけど
かなり大変でしたからね
だからそこで取っているポイントは
自分の過ちを教えてくれて
自分にアドバイスやらインストラクションやらね
そっちを言う人のことを嫌いか好きかということなんです
あれこれやとやり方を教えてくれたり
正しいやり方を教えてくれたりする場合は
その人のことを嫌いか好きかと
もうその人のことを好きで好きだと思うならば
自分が善人であって成長の見込みはありますね
やっぱりうるさいんですよと
で そうですかと それで本人が悪人ということになるんです
成長はしない はい そこら辺で 2つ以上は言ってはいかんだからね
で 終了いたします